bom gente é primeiramente agradecer à
organização da fedex bauru é uma baita
de uma honra participar de um evento
dessa magnitude
há muito há muito tempo eu almejo por
uma tex e parece que é acontece muita
loucura é sempre almejei isso eu sempre
viu o murilo gun que é outro humorista
amigo nosso e ele sempre faz né meu é
apresentar-se loureiro né quem não sabe
ler
acho que todo mundo sabe ler aqui o meu
até meus 21 29 anos desculpa eu tinha
uma vida corriqueira uma vida de uma
pessoa normal e numa numa eu sou formado
aqui na unesp bauru em design em uma
churrascaria é de cinco anos de formado
começou aquelas brincadeiras bacanas é
vamos molhar os coleguinhas que você
passa a seco e aí eu falei 'não galera
deixo aqui o net a roupa sensual
uau e puro beleza no que eu pulei velho
aí vem um coleguinha bacana e colocou o
joelho no meu pescoço e fraturou a
quinta ea sexta vértebra esmagou a
medula
aí é resultado tetraplégica e você se
ver meu acaba com a vida muda tudo um
segundo muda completamente
todas as coisas que você tava acostumado
e só dá uma colada aqui e aí eu me
deparei com uma com duas opções né
e na verdade nossa
a opção não existe é a partir daí eu
tomei uma decisão de voltar à vida leva
eu fiquei três meses parado do pescoço
do parado do pescoço para baixo com né
com as mãos até uma tia minha que de
bauru que eu fiquei aqui no na unimed
bauru
ela tem lembrança disse que eu ficava
assim falava tinha um corte na cabeça
que eu não consigo
só que a partir daí eu falei meu
precisam ser não é assim você não vai
não há risco vai te derrubar e aí foram
dois anos de meus seis horas de
fisioterapia hidroterapia aquática é a
estimulação 5 terapia é tudo que
aparecia eu eu eu eu fazia e tanto é que
num quadro de tetraplegia hoje todo
mundo até me chama de um tropel
depoimento dela né que como que o cara
se movimento assim e os números aqui aí
bom durante a sua recuperação eu o
recebi alguns alguns pilares né conforme
ia passando e eu comecei de detectar
mula detectar algumas características e
alguns pilares que eu consegui me apoiar
melhor e levando a a superação é esses
pilares 1
hoje passa saúde amor e riso
agora meu pique porque a gente fala da
superação
primeiro quer lenta antagonista a
estagnação e eu acredito que o ser
humano se ele não se recuperar será a
gente tá vivendo como a 190 mil anos
atrás
surgiu o homo sapiens e como disse uma
colega nossa mulheres sabem né
é gente eu só preciso de uma água que
não parece pequeno hobby
falei que ia gostar da bom pode mudar o
slide era quando eu falo de paz é eu
falo de paz de espírito
durante todo esse processo de
recuperação
eu tenho que lidar com muita coisa muita
muitas pessoas que não não tem paz de
espírito é e como você combate isso
gente combate com mais paz de espírito
demonstrando isso para as pessoas e
assim é imaginar a cena eu como uma
pessoa tetraplégica
se alguém me deixar numa cama sem acesso
à minha cadeira de rodas
parecendo aqueles besouro que fica sem
saber que numa rede levaram à não eu não
saio e aí a pessoa que ela pode fazer
ela pode falar qualquer desaforo pra mim
e sai andando e aí um cara que tem que
ficar ouvindo meu engolir um sapo boi só
com um sapo boi mas de um sapo do
tamanho de um burro não sabe bem que meu
pé é um é difícil é complicado mas a
gente aprende isso com paciência e mel
essa paz de espírito num hoje eu vejo
que não têm o que não tem preço que paga
é eu aprendi uma técnica que eu vou
pedir solicitar que vocês adotem a onu
momentos me deixa eu num é muito mais
uma uma questão de mudar vibração em
relação às coisas
na posição de lótus você pode fazer isso
no seu escritório em seu trabalho só que
meu é uma técnica
procure no nesse site novo tem de vídeo
no youtube
se procuram lá é fácil só e no youtube
trocar o no momento ele tejo está e é
muito legal porque meu acontece num
instante e você muda a vibração e isso
traz uma paz de espírito muito legal
bom gente é eu gosto muito dessa frase é
uma frase de desfecho do dom do
pensamento mujica também foi bené chega
a neve a lembra
então esse pensamento da música
ele é um desfecho e onde ele fala é
sobre essa sociedade consumista que a
gente criou que sempre o melhor sempre a
gente está tendo que ter o mais mais
novo e vai-vai muito ano né fazendo
monteiro em casa
só que a gente não percebe que a gente
gasta quando a gente compra uma coisa a
gente não compra essa coisa com dinheiro
a gente compra com o tempo de vida que a
gente gastou pra ganhar esse dinheiro e
ele fala é miserável gastar a vida pra
se perder a liberdade agora é eu faço
uma analogia faz uma comparação que eu
acho miserável a gente gastar nossa vida
para deixar qualquer coisa ou qualquer
pessoa tira a nossa paz de espírito
até ontem eu estava fazendo um barzinho
de pra ouvir rock'n'roll ea banda tocou
sei lá dez minutos a menos de um cara eu
estamos se degladiando por causa de 50
reais
então eu acho que a gente deve ponderar
será que será que essa pessoa que falou
essa coisa tão pequena vai tirar minha
paz de espírito na vida tá correndo
acho que a gente não pode dar ao luxo a
outra pessoa de tirar isso da gente pode
dar um chá quente saúde seguinte jeito é
são três perguntas que eu quero fazer
aqui pra vocês que passar aqui quanto os
perrengues a gente tem por dia para
resolver
a segunda pergunta é como é o sistema de
saúde do brasil hoje em dia e a terceira
pergunta é meu pra quem jamais problema
então eu lembro quando eu sofri meu
acidente fiquei 14 dias
muito louco muito doido de tramal
morfina e foi bom mas do jeito né ii e
eu lembro que eu chorava
pra que eu queria uma cadeira higiênica
uma cadeira de banho para poder tomar
banho de chuveiro que até então pessoal
só passava pano em mim passar um pano e
meio é uma coisa que ninguém quer é
ficar hospitalizado
eu hoje tomou
são 14 oito remédios dia quem de 40
remédios mês
então é eu acho que eu acho que na
verdade por exemplo nem preciso falar
sobre o uso de drogas como eu que isso é
arranjar problema é fica mal eu eu gosto
de frisar
é o passagem todos nós somos adultos
aqui a gente não sabe das consequências
das nossas ações e só que eu queria cá é
falar da pior droga de todas
eu acho que o álcool inclusive porque
ela é uma droga é liberada
então ela pode causar
são efeitos bem chocante bem a pessoa
que se entrega ao álcool é infelizmente
eu vou ter que mostrar isso aqui tá você
pode passar pra mim
os dó pode acontecer isso a gente não
tomem cuidado e mel pode dar uma esses
cuidados com a saúde eu por exemplo como
eu não ando então é um problema muito
chato que chama-se digestão galera é pra
não ter mais um problema na vida ocorrer
uma alimentação boa é é não precisa ser
o neo o cara que pega a corda de navio
faz com os pit mas meu tendão aquela
aquela aquele cuidado com a saúde eu
acho que é um pilar é bem bem fincado né
pra pra gente pra gente se firmar nele e
é uma coisa que eu também prático
analisando esse plano mais uma vez tenta
sempre toca trocar de rotina sempre tem
alguma coisa nova num no ano novo numa
semana nova porque senão é eu gosto
dessa fase por causa disso ela se não
você não vai viver o mesmo ano 80 vezes
e falar por isso aí foi minha vida
isso aí é saúde mental beleza pode lavar
vamos falar sobre amor mas não aquele
amor de sobre um só
um homem com uma mulher
enfim amor pela vida é depois do do
acidente eu criei um amor pela vida
muito maior
aprendi a dar valor é essa vida que levo
creio que pra crer que assim o amor pelo
próximo né
eu não tinha sentido nenhum na vida a
não ser o amor por ela própria e pelo
próximo e daum começar a palestrar fazer
stand-up todas essas coisas pode dar uma
e outra
outra coisa que a gente demonstra o amor
por essa vida é através de gratidão que
naturalmente o alinhamento na entre o
cérebro eo coração e eu pratico gratidão
bastante e gostaria que vocês lessem
essa frase pra poder
a gente vê o quanto é necessário essa
gratidão se a gente acordar só porque a
gente agradeceu hoje e amanhã
só porque a gente agradeceu hoje então
eu pratico sempre essa coisa de acordar
e e agradecer tudo que eu tenho ainda o
riso
segundo o bruno morta que é minha praia
né fazendo stand up cara não tem coisa
mais gostosa no mundo do que o riso é o
gol eu sempre fui assim o idiota do
vasco sabe fazer piada do mundo mexe com
todo mundo e eu não iria deixar que a
lesão medular me tirasse isso eu até vou
convocar vocês agora a ver um vídeo
bem bacana e eu quero ou é apostar com
vocês eu quero atingir vocês quero falar
meu não riem deste vídeo tentando rir e
aprender
ó
a salva de palmas para os vídeos devem
bom gente é pra finalizar que
finalizando a a palestra com vocês sobre
a paz nem para a saúde amor e riso
imagino com um improvável é um futuro de
uma pessoa que pede por um segundo a
cabeça e tem uma arma na mão e uma briga
no trânsito quanto a paz de espírito
falta do país espírito nunca traz um
futuro improvável a uma pessoa tem um
avc na sala de casa por não ter cuidado
da saúde se essa pessoa é o provedor de
uma família klein com o improvável num
vai ser o futuro dessa dessa família a
uma pessoa que não tem amor mais pela
vida pode ter depressão isso levar um
suicídio
o com futuro né com um improvável vai
ser o futuro para elas é que vai existir
e o pior é de todos os os futuros as
improváveis eu acho que é uma sociedade
que não ri e eu gostaria de encerrar com
essa frase do osso que as pessoas estão
levando tão a sério e isso se torna um
fardo para elas vão aprender mais
a risada é tão sagrada quanto à prece
valeu meu nome é mauricio loureiro muita
paz saúde amor e isso pra vocês